الآن ، صراع على السلطة من نوع مختلف
بين جنرالين متحاربين قد أدخل
السودان في أزمة بعد المحاولة الأولى الفاشلة
لوقف إطلاق النار ، وافق الجيش السوداني
والقوات شبه العسكرية الآن
على وقف القتال لمدة 24 ساعة.
أفادت الأنباء أن المستشفيات في العاصمة الخرطوم قد توقفت عن العمل الآن ، حيث
أخبرت الجمعية الطبية بالبلاد شبكة CNN
أنه في ظل عدم وجود أطباء لرعايتهم ، فإن
القتلى والمصابين
يُتركون للتعفن في أسرتهم.
ساحة المعركة ونقص
الإمدادات الطبية والكهرباء يجعل
الوضع أسوأ حتى تشير التقديرات الرسمية إلى أن
عدد القتلى حتى الآن يصل إلى ما يقرب من
300 مع أكثر من 3000 جريح الآن مع
تحرك اليابان لإجلاء مواطنيها ،
علمت سي إن إن أن منازل الأمم المتحدة
تمت مداهمات الموظفين والمنظمات الدولية الأخرى
بتقارير عن اعتداء جنسي واغتصاب. معهد حميد
الخلافلة لسياسات
الشرق الأوسط
انضم إلي الآن من العاصمة السودانية ،
مرحبًا بكم في البرنامج ، اسمحوا لي أن أبدأ
بسؤالك يا سيد خلفالا عن مدى الأمل الذي
تضعه في هذه الفكرة.  وقف إطلاق النار لمدة 24 ساعة
أه ليس هناك أمل كبير أه لأكون صادقًا
هذا هو قال أه وقف إطلاق النار الذي
سيعلن أه أول أمس
ثلاث ساعات لم يتم الإعلان عن هذا إطلاق النار ولم يتم الإعلان عن أي
من القوات الملتزمة به
مساء أمس إطلاق سلسلة 24 ساعة  لم
يعلن عن أي من القوات الملتزمة
به أه الآن منذ ساعة أه
بدأ وقف إطلاق النار الجديد حتى الآن أستطيع أن أقول أنه
كان أكثر هدوءًا لدرجة أنني كنت
أصاب أقل إطلاق نار من
حولي وهكذا أه ولكن من الصعب
إخبارك بذلك  أعلم أن هذا سيستمر
خلال الـ 24 ساعة القادمة ، ليس لدى قادة الساحل
الإرادة الفعلية للالتزام
بوقف إطلاق النار ، كل واحد منهم يحاول
المضي قدمًا في أي شيء آخر ،
ويحقق المزيد من المكاسب قبل أن يتمكنوا من
مناقشة هذه الحرائق
ومحادثات السلام المحتملة  وما إلى ذلك وأيضًا
لا يتمتع معظمهم بالسيطرة الكاملة وخفة
الحركة لفرض
وقف إطلاق النار هذا على تلك القوات والقوات بإذن
الله سيد خليفة ، دعني أطلب منك أن
تضع ذلك بإيجاز ودقة قدر
المستطاع  مشاهدينا كيف وصل الأمر إلى
هذا قبل أربع سنوات كان هناك أمل بعد
الإطاحة
بالديكتاتور العسكري عمر البشير
من قبل المحكمة الجنائية الدولية ، ثم كان لديك الأطراف التي
وافقت على تقاسم السلطة كما تعلمون
هيئة انتقالية قد تؤدي  إلى
الديمقراطية هذا ما
أراده شعب السودان ما حدث في
الفترة الانتقالية
من الواضح أن هناك العديد من القضايا التي
أدت إلى اللحظة التي نحن فيها الآن ولكن
أعتقد أن السبب الرئيسي هو أن
لديك مجموعة شبه عسكرية أه أه عنيفة جدًا
مهما كانت  كان له
دور سياسي واه كبير ودور كبير في هذا
الاقتصاد السوداني وبعد ذلك لديك هذا هو
الجيش الجديد الذي تمت إدارته بشكل سيئ للغاية أه وسوء
إدارته على مدار الثلاثين عامًا الماضية منذ أن
تولى أه الرئيس البشير أه ليصبح جيشًا
الرئيس في عام 1989. لذلك مع هاتين
المؤسستين المضطربتين للغاية ،
كان الانتقال دائمًا
هشًا الآن ، وقد وجدت هاتان المؤسستان
بعض الطرق للعمل معًا
على مدار السنوات الأربع الماضية لأنهما
سيفوزان بالمزيد من خلال العمل
معًا وربط مصالحهما
معًا ولكن  وصلت إلى نقطة
حيث نقاشات إصلاح قطاع الأمن
أه أه حيث نحن
جاريون للتو أه كانت هناك نقاشات حول
تكامل إثنين من
القوتين أه لأننا لا نستطيع أن يكون لدينا جيشان
وهكذا دواليك
وهذا ما أدى  حتى
اللحظة الحالية ، لذا فإن صراعًا كلاسيكيًا على السلطة
مع كل جانب يحاول أن يكون أه له
السيادة هناك حتى نعلم أن
الدول الغربية لجامعة الدول العربية بالطبع
دعت الولايات المتحدة جميعًا إلى
وقف إطلاق النار ومحاولاتهم لمحاولة
التوسط والحصول على كليهما  من الأطراف التي تعرفها
لإلغاء هذا الأمر الذي
نعرفه من مبعوث الولايات المتحدة السابق
إلى القرن الأفريقي جيفري فتلمان ،
هذا ما قاله إنه من
المحتمل أن يكون الوضع الحالي
متوقعًا في عام 2021 واصفًا
تعاملاته ، ثم قال إننا تجنبنا
الإلزام.  عواقب أفعال
الإفلات من العقاب المتكررة التي كان من الممكن أن
تفرض تغييرًا في حساباتهم بدلاً من ذلك ،
وبدلاً من ذلك ، استرضينا بشكل انعكاسي
واستوعبنا أمراء الحرب اللذين
اعتبرنا أنفسنا أنفسنا واقعيًا بعد فوات الأوان ،
يوحي التفكير بالتمني ليكون
وصفًا أكثر دقة ، هل توافق على
ذلك
بالتأكيد أنا أتفق مع ذلك  أعتقد
الكثير من
الطموحات التي يمتلكها الزعيمان الآن
حيث تأثر وتشجع من نواحٍ عديدة
العملية السياسية أه أه حيث
سمح لهم المجتمع الدولي
بالمطالبة بالأماكن التي يطالبون بها حاليًا
ومنحهم ذلك
أه أنت  اعلم أن
امتياز التسليم هذا أه حتى الآن عندما
كانت العملية شخصًا سياسيًا كانت
تقترب من نهايتها ، كما أن الدخول إلى
السودان كان يدعو إلى حكومة انتقالية مدنية بالكامل ،
ظل المجتمع الدولي
يكرر نفس العبارة مثل
حكومة يقودها مدنيون أينما كانوا
يلمحون بأنهم مازالوا يتدحرجون
للجيش أه للعب في هذه
الحكومة القادمة لذلك حتى عندما كان المدنيون
يضغطون من أجل القدرة على الخروج
تمامًا من
المجتمع الدولي ظلوا يلمحون أن
هناك مجالًا لذلك والأهم واضح
أه المصلحة أه
المجتمع الدولي هل كنت تعلم تبحث عن
الأمن في بلدهم والحفاظ
على الجيش الذي اعتقدوا أنه سيحافظ على
الأمن ويحافظ على الأمن والاستقرار في السودان وبالتالي فإن
المنطقة بأكملها في موطن إفريقيا
ستكون آمنة ومستقرة الآن يمكننا أن نرى  ما
تعرفه عن تضمين
القادة العسكريين في السياسة وما
تحتاجه ، لذا هل يمكنني أن أسألك شيئًا عن
المشاركة المحتملة لروسيا ، هل
لديك أي سبب للاعتقاد بأنها أو
وكلائها هناك ربما كان لديهم أي شيء
للقيام بذلك وأنا أسألك  لأنك
تعلم أن روسيا كانت تحقق
نجاحات كبيرة ، فإن مجموعة فاغنر التي تديرها أنت تعرف
بريجوسيان أن أمير الحرب أه قد وضع
مرتزقته على الأرض ،
كشف تحقيق سي إن إن عن مخطط
لتصدير ذهب السودان سرًا لتمويل
الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا من خلال
شركة خاضعة للعقوبات الأمريكية  يسمى نخاع
الذهب الذي كان مملوكًا
لمؤسس فاغنر ، هل لديك أي سبب للاعتقاد
أم تعلم أن هذا هو الحال
وكما تعلمون وزير الخارجية الروسي
كان في السودان أه
منذ عدة أشهر ،
روسيا بالتأكيد منخرطة في
هذا العالم  بطريقة أو بأخرى
والمشاركة لروسيا كانت دائمًا
جزءًا من ديناميكيات أه
وتعقيدات الاقتصاد السياسي السوداني
وكيف أنه كان من الصعب
التنقل ولكن ليس فقط روسيا بل هناك
الكثير من الدول الإقليمية والممكنة الأخرى  لقد
لعبت أه في رأيي أدوارًا سلبية جدًا
كدعم أحد هؤلاء الممثلين
أو الآخر أه
أنا قوى الدعم السريع
لكن أعتقد أن هناك أيضًا مشكلة
عندما نركز أه كل الاهتمام
على كيفية هذا أه  الكود الحالي هو نتاج
تدخل روسيا وهكذا فهو
يقلل الكثير من التعقيدات أه
في السياق السوداني لذا فهو
جزء من المشكلة لكن هناك
العديد من المشاكل الأخرى أه
أنت تعرف المشاكل ، حسنًا